oh the show would be inexorably altered
you know you would you'd you'd be
altered by like what but what are you
saying
don't say that like you would read it
and then that would be the show the show
would be these people as well as you
well it's just not necessarily or so
because of the fact that we had the
comments killed during the live feed you
couldn't you couldn't chat during the
live feed when we would transfer it over
to YouTube the comments would be
disabled and people went crazy and I had
to tweet about it but look I'm not
disabling the comments I don't know what
this glitch is but they're gonna figure
it out but Shaab decided to disable his
comments on purpose and do they [ __ ]
went crazy and they were attacking him
but what are the numbers that give a
[ __ ] like you have you ever commented on
a YouTube video have you ever watched a
YouTube video in comments and I don't
think I ever have I never have you know
I don't know anybody worth a [ __ ] that
has like that's the part of the problem
it's like I know there's some really
positive comments and people who are
healthy people were just interested in
debate and discussion about particular
topics but when you're dealing with all
these negative people like what are the
numbers if you have a million people
watching a YouTube video or you'll be
talking about 100 people a thousand is
it even a 200 it might not even be a
hundred you might dealing with like
thirty [ __ ] yeah you know I mean and
they're the ones who are gonna be mad
that you disable the comments but does
that really matter and it is this is
keeping the that cesspool open keeping
that commode open for them to dump their
[ __ ] verbal diarrhea into is that
really feeding the bait is that giving
the kid candy for being an [ __ ] was
it the same thing maybe maybe I once saw
you stand and talk to 600 people who
came to your show you had an in-depth
conversation chemtrails this and [ __ ]
fighting that with each of them in the
eye you spent for sure four hours when
you took a bunch of friends out for
dinner and he invited me which was
really cool by the way thank you i brag
about all of that and then I saw you
walk across that was four hours for sure
okay two to four hours I don't know the
exact number then I see a walk across
the casino in
that time you do it again for another
half-hour as you know Joey Diaz and then
we sit down and somebody comes over as
soon as you sit down and they say hey
can I and you go [ __ ] off man a meeting
that's the guy who will tell the world
Joe Rogan's an [ __ ] you can't just
stop your meal every time someone comes
over hundred inter like human deep
interactions meaningful interactions
that one can [ __ ] off well I don't want
to say [ __ ] off I just think that people
have this distorted idea of space that
they should just be able to invade your
space where you literally have a mouth
full of food yeah I mean I've had it
happen I've had it happen while I was
feeding my daughter have her in my lap
heel broke I get a selfie but you
definitely can't get a selfie right now
I'm feeding my daughter get the [ __ ] out
of here man that's just a
misunderstanding of space yeah and
you're human yeah like there it is a
strange thing I mean I didn't watch my
wife was asking me because I was in
Singapore if I watch The Royal Wedding
I'm like no I understand the motivation
for doing it but those are still humans
yeah like those are still people there
and that's people don't understand that
woman [ __ ]
she died side this way here yeah you
know what I mean they just they're
people and can you imagine if the person
asks you why you're feeding your
daughter somebody did that maybe the
first time you'd be like well I can't
believe it's good once take selfie with
me but after that it would be you're
still living your human life yeah I'm
the only one you have
you just can't interrupt people while
they're sitting at dinner with their
family or with their friends they're
just sitting there cutting food up it's
just like they don't owe you that like
and you shouldn't ask for that it's just
not the way to do it it's just not and
you gotta know when people can't stop
they just can't just say hi can you just
say hi yeah no one can say hi everybody
wants to dress up their Facebook
everyone needs that [ __ ] selfie it's
just like we're wearing a weird space
with that stuff that that whole social
media [ __ ] because people want something
from you that they get up to it's not
just they're a fan and they want to say
hi they want something from you to make
them look cooler and it's like you
you can give them some currency it's
like you're a Pokemon and they can pick
you up and and and get a point for it's
weird
so I